hello rejects Greg Alba here with the
lovely Julie lon
Julie's on Julie's on fire
Julie's on from the channels shut up and
dances here met this lovely lady in
Switzerland we saw la-la-land to get oh
my god we both cried she cried okay
we're sitting really cried I would well
my goal after the movie was like the
credits were done yeah Greg's like you
want to review this with me I was like I
gotta go think about life right now and
I got worried for you and I was like I
ask you another be like anyone here from
Julie she's just like left that was an
impactful film oh my god
but yes now we're in happier times and
Ryan Gosling Emma Stone ER and it's
speaking of celebrities we're gonna do a
video from top trending 10 most
embarrassing celebrity fails oh boy I'm
sure we've probably heard of all of
these I don't know I sometimes live
under a rock
I'm telling you Julie making fun of
celebrities is the best thing you can do
one day you will be a celebrity maybe
you're already like a what letter a
celebrity are we right now like a like a
oh not now the Z list we're like a yeah
there's some let's just talk about these
guys in their failures
[Music]
Oh No I wish I was there for that fail
yeah OSR from number one Jennifer
Lawrence has been described as the funny
girl next door that is totally cool and
down to earth
Henry Diaz is taking the down-to-earth
part a little too literal
she has tripped at award shows two years
in a row in 2013 she tripped going up
the steps to accept the award for Best
Actress unfortunately she might have
been a little too excited to concentrate
on not walking all over that humongous
white dress that same year at the SAG
Awards she tripped over some hidden lace
in her dress as she grabbed some nearby
chairs for stability then the following
year SHA red carpet nesters leave it to
Jayla to flop over something meant to
deter people from danger then at the
premiere of The Hunger Games part two
her heel got stuck on the train of her
dress and she took a dramatic tumble
somebody this girl akkanee
Wow Jennifer Lawrence's clumsy I didn't
know it was that bad I've heard of like
maybe one of them she's that she's that
down-to-earth though Julie maybe she's
just drunk and stoned at every one of
these things she's admitted to showing
up to places stone sometimes drunk
actually if you're JWoww sure she is a
cool girl like I love her more in
interviews like I think she's a great
actress I do I think she's an amazing
actress
but I still love her more in interviews
and stuff that I do
watching a role she does I wasn't both
equal ways I don't know I like love her
in those movies but I like I'm like in
love with her when I watch like an
interview you know what it is it's
because in movies there's something a
little bit removed and mysterious about
her why can't I ever be that right I
never know life she's just so real yeah
yeah she's just so cool so awesome no
this is good I mean was her face no you
were Syria she's tripped and fell but I
feel like this one is more like down
she's her bigger celebrity though that's
Jim yeah she has respect hmm we laughed
we laughed ha kings of YouTube ha ha ha
Madonna has been performing on stages
for dick that's why she adopted kids so
she should have hundreds of thousands of
cheering adoring fans has become second
nature but recently the 58 year old
popstar had a huge wardrobe malfunction
this is her tumbling down the stage on
her back all because she wanted to play
dress up at the 2015 Brit Awards she'd
down the entire that looks like a
spanish matador including a long flowing
red and black cape apparently it was
supposed to come off when it was pulled
away but it was tied too tight she flew
backwards on a small flight of stairs
but like a true professional she popped
right back my head bones broken the
advice of Edna from The Incredibles no
case momma DOM is a trooper hey who's
that who's that dude we oh I think you
knew him before but I had just met him
in Switzerland the guy plays the violin
oh yeah Jason yang he he tour with
Madonna for like a year
oh my god yeah how do I not know they
like toured with Madonna for like a full
year I feel like my friends are so much
more amazing than I give them credit
- yeah you said Madonna's like a really
really cool girl she taught him a lot
about actually humility and when to talk
and stuff about yourself and and I feel
I have to make Jason so cool because he
inquires a lot about people but then
like then he never shows find out that
he Tohru Madonna through other people
telling you dr. Jason do you want to
show off like yeah yeah that's what you
know you're really made it cuz you don't
have to say [ __ ] about yourself yeah I
constantly have to try to sell myself
you know hopefully trying to somebody oh
my god Madonna I feel like that could
have broken someone's head
yeah but why she got up yeah it would
have been coaching like a Chinese kept
up like that would have been sweet I
learned to do that this week oh really
and then got a pinched nerve go Madonna
you're superwoman we now live in an age
where the word Fergalicious is
synonymous with sexy and that was hit
Purvi of Black Eyed Peas fame says that
she's got the milkman but fans of our
over completely I just saw her pee her
pants now stage in the middle of a
performance she describes it as
most unattractive moment of her life and
she describes the events she and the
Black Eyed Peas were late for a
performance and had to rush on the stage
oh my god she was getting the crowd hype
jumping around more than a few squirts
of urine stains to try to cover up that
I just wet my pants look she poured
water all over herself hey don't worry
Stacy it happens to the best of us not
me of course no way I had no idea that
ever I didn't know that either oh my god
poor Fergie
oh that that just makes me respect you a
lot more now because you're just a human
being with struggles like to rest that
is true have you ever peed yourself when
I was in Taekwondo when I was like five
years old five five days away right now
I doll yeah my ex ex-girlfriend um peed
on you know I don't know I woke up one
day and I like peed in the bed and as I
was like 20 I always say every adult is
allowed like one of those yeah that was
my one time I've done it since this is
being an adult I do I used to pee on
[ __ ] all the time I was it
Wow good I would like oh I was the kind
of kid a sleepwalking pee on something
is that I don't know it's a thing
your Neri paralysis oh maybe it's like a
dominance thing you're like this is yeah
this is my couch and then you blame it
on this just my bed now mom and dad Wow
that's awesome that she like poured
water on herself yeah that is smart but
I mean ever a lot of people clearly
notice as she Ashley peed on herself
I'm sure it's embarrassing moment but
she's still match to thrive after such
an embarrassing moment well she does
this you just laugh about it now you
know and that's so smart to just you
guys [ __ ] laugh about it there's a
lot of people would might just cower
away after something like that you know
or deny it
yeah but she's like listen they didn't
give me time to pee yeah I do you can't
ever let a woman holding her Puran ever
that's when women have to go sounded
like experience
okay well women have to go pee you
ladies get violent like you understand
and you go to bathroom right oh my guys
I feel I can hold it in
right I just really gotta take a piss
but hold it in look girls are just like
I can't put this on anything right now
until I go to the bathroom that's true
well girls we have a percentage kind of
point system so when I'm with my girls
and we're like I got a pee they're like
what percent I'm like 65 now like okay
well have some time to find a bathroom
but when you're like 90 90 then everyone
freaks out that's what we do or maybe
just me yeah that's what all women do
you know constantly hear women asking
themselves what percentage are you y'all
forget her the queen bee of R&B beyonce
continues to headline shows across the
world for sold-out crowds people can't
get enough of the former Destiny's time
and she's not afraid to get close to the
fans but not that kind of fan during her
2013 mrs. Carter world tour she stopped
off in Montreal while singing her hit
single halo she stepped down to greet
the people she ended up getting her hair
caught in an on-stage motorized and her
head slams back and a security guard had
to cut her loose but can you believe
that she didn't even miss a beat or a
tune during the entire ordeal she just
kept on singing a true professional
giving the fans what they want
regardless of the immediate situation
expect for them but next time keep the
fans at bay
Beyonce home girl oh my god she she's
already been my hero but after that she
did did you see that she did like no
reaction she's like oh that happened
ma'am is ready Madonna and Beyonce
predict that's why they're the Queen's
that's whether they're professionals no
matter what happens the show must keep
going that's pro that's that's mad
respect that is mad respect was that her
real hair maybe that's why she's like oh
that's a weave it yeah I just kind of
baby you got a good point there yeah
Miami so professional after all the
Beyonce where are we everybody loves the
Netflix hit series orange is the new
black nursing with the Stars champion
Julianne Hough wanted to express her
love for the show by dressing up as one
of the characters for Halloween
think she picked the wrong one though
now has the character crazy eyes
complete with orange prison jumpsuit a
knotted hairdo and darkened skin some
people saw her get up as derogatory
blackface we're people a fairer skin
tone imitates black people in order to
ridicule them in a racist fashion
pictures of her in her costume quickly
made its rounds online outrage and
criticism the next day on Twitter she
issued an apology stating it certainly
was never my intention to be
disrespectful or demeaning to anyone in
any way I realized my costume hurt and
offended people and I truly apologize we
can forgive Julianne home because she's
hot well oh wow that's the rule right or
we can forgive her because it sounded
like she was genuine it sound like it's
just a joke yeah thing versus oh I hate
I hate black people yeah I didn't get
that vibe from her I don't think it was
that no I feel like don't don't you have
friends that tell you like dude you're
like a celebrity and you're about to do
this thing that's probably gonna be a
bad idea I think a lot of famous people
go through moments in their life with
her like I don't I don't want to care
what people think
and then they end up apologizing a lot
yeah cuz that was pretty offensive
awkward let's ask you this yeah you're
you full Chinese partially full Chinese
right but what if she like dressed up as
like an Asian character and like did
something with her eyes yeah I would not
accept an apology but you know if it was
like with the intention of oh I'm a fan
of this Asian like I'm wrong here like a
Mulan character you know I get it it's
so kind of weird and offensive but this
Halloween though is so funny I went to
this party and this Asian guy had on
like a preppy outfit and then painted
his face white and I was like hey what
are you and he said I'm privileged like
it's not reverse yeah I feel like the
one race you can't you can make fun of
his white people the only people that
take offense the only whites take
offense are commentators on the Internet
who will stand up for themselves
publicly through a protected you to baby
tell us what you think in the gun I'll
listen the car I'm sorry don't like that
just like my grandma used to say never
stick a fork in a power outlet and never
stick your finger in a drone propellers
okay she never said that last part but
enrique inglesias should probably take
that a bus in a 5 to 15 concert in
Tijuana Mexico the 40 year old singer
used a flying drone to capture some
insane up close POV shots of him and his
fans as he went to grab the drone his
hand got caught in the spinning blades
which left his hands severely cut and
bloody and we're getting a quick bandage
backstage he went back out and continued
his perform hell yeah the entire time in
his own words he expressed the show must
go on what a guy that's some reason he
felt the need to draw heart on his shirt
with his own blood after the show he was
rushed to an airport in an ambulance and
flew to a Los Angeles hospital for
medical attention he made a full
recovery
the idea of Enrique Iglesias becoming
like delusional from the loss of blood
like this Joe was go on oh my god what
maybe they gave him like massive
painters or something and then he got
delirious oh god dude that was crazy
again mad respect mad respect for a
little nuts at the end Wow this will be
cool oh yeah at least it was a heart I
mean I draw something offensive on his
wife yeah that's true look what he was
enjoying it though yeah I felt like he
was having a good life guys I mean apart
with my lunch three gay Enrique respect
doc John Travolta is basically an
international movie star basically they
asked him to introduce performer I'll
award shows well maybe he should
practice reading the names though during
the 2014 Academy Award Show he
mispronounced Idina Menzel's name as she
was about to perform her hit song let it
go from the movie frozen but he didn't
just mispronounce the name he completely
changed it hilariously he called her the
wicked
talented one-and-only adele dazeem of
course everyone went to social media to
Travolta sized people's names later that
night he went on Jimmy Kimmel to explain
what happened he said that at the last
minute they changed her name on the
teleprompter to a phonetic spelling
rather than the regular spelling in his
public apology he says I've been beating
myself up all day then I thought what
would idina menzel say she'd say let it
go Wow yeah sure she heard that old song
everything right oh did you know I never
noticed that I mean I saw that award
show but I did yeah I don't think I was
like it was the talk of the town was it
I didn't know they changed it to a
phonetic thing what I heard was that
he's dyslexic and so it was because the
name like I guess triggered his dyslexia
or something which that's understandable
okay I have a theory okay - theory hey
he either is really dyslexic B he's a
Scientologist Tom Cruise publicly talks
about the fact that he was dyslexic and
Scientology cured that maybe people just
got it confused or maybe more maybe this
is just a Google search away and I yeah
I know but maybe Scientology gave him
dyslexia Oh No twist twist ending there
Adele movies almost ten damn in the
music industry not many can match the
vocal prowess of Christina Aguilera I
can go in 2012 when three year old
legendary singer Etta James passed away
Christina was invited to perform at his
classic song at last
well criticized her rendition may have
been over-the-top others wondered what
that brown stuff was that was dripping
down her leg Oh started to speculate
that the singer may have had running
diarrhea or maybe it was just that time
of the month but fortunately for us all
it was just spray tan apparently it got
a little too hot between the sides so
the sweat and the fake spray tan started
to drip down despite the mishap she gave
a heartfelt performance at the funeral
anchor describing it as one of the
proudest moments of her life singing for
her idol
she pooped dick she boobs you spray tans
a good excuse
it is a clever excuse yeah hey that's
smart you got it you got a great
publicist um but that is not true I mean
I can tell I know what tyria poop looks
like I've seen it on people I'm that
well so I I've been a fan of Christina's
version of that last for a long time but
she's it's like powerful would you like
Oh oops
right it's like you got it it's hotter
than just the heisman she's gonna see
yeah maybe it causes pooping to happen
like Fergie peed because she was she
seems in the stomach you know yeah yeah
which causes poop power but it's such
one singers tend to be thin as they just
[ __ ] themselves should do so much
onstage all it's not uncommon thing
which is happen she's having learned
something you see it yeah we're all
human all human we all [ __ ] her it's
okay
yeah One Direction is probably the
biggest boy band in the world mr. Paz
doubtedly
Harry Styles is the most popular one out
of the group is around him take an epic
tumble on stage they all share the good
laugh back in 2015 at the start of their
North American tour the boys were
belting out the lyrics to some of their
biggest hits Harry Styles lost his
footing and tried to counterbalance by
doing some sort of matrix style lean I
guess he didn't quite understand the
gravity of the situation as he fell
backwards on stage leaving his fellow
bandmates struggling with laughter fans
took to Twitter and started the playful
hashtag oh no Harry poking a little fun
at their superstar drink boy Wow wasn't
that bad it wasn't a man yeah there was
ravers yeah McDonagh like fell down his
stairs he it was like a slow-motion like
he didn't have a good song it's also the
way he handled it was really cool
yeah like yeah he made some weird move
when he was falling but like I'm a goofy
he accepted it like yeah down that's
again he was like a no that was
embarrassing
but you know like he just accepted as I
don't know the
this thing amongst twelve-year-old girls
so yeah exactly exactly it's all we want
is to be hot amongst twelve-year-old
girls no any 12 year old fans out there
there are we love with Greg and then met
a couple that's adorable oh don't give
them your number
American heartthrob Justin Bieber has
done some pressing things during his
singing
could we just punched a van so at this
point one would believe that it would be
hard to be embarrassed about anything so
we got to go back to 2012 at the start
of his tour in Glendale Arizona Justin
wasn't feeling too well
but decided to perform anyway during the
middle of the show he leaned over
mysteriously which is back to the
audience and proceeded to vomit
profusely after blowing chunks
the singer ran for the side of the stage
the show went on though as the striking
vocals and backup dancers continued as
if nothing ever happened later he posted
on Twitter that he was getting better
and hope for a better show in the next
city I guess you could say that he
succumbed to his own Bieber fever God
[Music]
top trending you and your humor guys
subscribe to this channel they're a
fantastic Channel
Bieber fever holy crap I've seen Bieber
do some crazy things on TMZ I actually
haven't I don't know one video where he
I mean there's one award show where he
like started insulting the audience's
they all started booing him for winning
an award and then there was this other
thing where he was at getting an
evangelist for me so I've taken a fight
with a fan who like said some [ __ ] to
him or something maybe not a fan but
like a paparazzi dude oh and then this
other video I saw like a week ago he was
driving with his window down after a
concert and then fans were rushing to
him one fan this guy put his hand on
this chest while he's in the car and
just if you touched him right in the
face right here maybe they caught it
like you've played in slow-motion it's
pretty cool
but maybe you know what if someone's
reaching for my chest I would probably
punch them too well he just wanted to
decide one thing we just want to touch
the celebrity I look here's what I think
if you're Justin Bieber
at this point in your career like that's
true like hey you shouldn't be touching
the guy I get that however with that
being said if you're Justin Bieber you
know better than by now to drive through
a crowd with your lip whatever window
all the way down and not expect someone
to try to touch you that's true is this
gonna go in their resume we keep my
distance
it's his fault yeah kudos to him for
going onstage even though you felt like
throw and then doing it
Justin Bieber has become my favorite
celebrity whose actual work I don't
follow okay
he's like favorite so what he's good
songs that's I hear he's been gaining a
lot of respect he's kind of doing like
that Justin Timberlake thing where he
start off like a pretty boy and now
you're actually being respected and I
feel like Justin Bieber's getting that a
lot too like he start off as a pretty
boy but lately has been getting a lot of
respect I'm pretty boy but come on I'll
keep my opinions he was like the solo
One Direction for a while no he's got a
great voice I just must have been
attracted to him
how old is he yeah I still think he's
ten I think he's like five years old
when he started
I'll never view him as an adult it was a
little kid to me yeah all right rejects
thanks for tuning in to the channel if
you're new to it subscribe today come
accept it
Julie's on is shut up and dance on
YouTube just shut up and dance the
perfect channel watch me too drunk dance
yeah does based off Julie's childhood of
her being forced to dance all the time
and not to perform for the political
leaders in China there might be truth
that might be now and you got her
Instagram and Twitter dance juju dance
she's got some good photos on there
that's that it way I never know how to
properly promote it Instagram yeah
there's some great photos of this girl
no nudies or anything
nobody can there's some girls on
Instagram I got away with like pretty
much nudity there no way well I actually
have seen it counselor like there are
there is nudity on it like just full-out
nudity but now all you're just so across
them all your viewers
wondering what those I bet old Muslim
know